Hey, Will. Hello there. Hey, Sean. Will, you got some real sweaty pits today. Are you concerned about anything? Are you nervous? I am nervous. I just took a lie detector. Oh, wow. And what was the result? I'm a liar. Anyway, this episode is going to be great. Yeah, we're going to work out some truth. Yeah, it's an all new Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart.
Less. Smart. Less. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic.
Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic, hot mics, hot mics. Hi, hot mics. Hey, hi, hot mics. Hot mics. Send us pics of all your hot mics. Post them on our page.
We'd love to take a look at all your hot mics. He's so tired, he's still got it. So tired, still got it. Sean, you had a hot bob once, didn't you? I had a hot toddy, a hot bob and a hot mic. You ever had a hot bob haircut? Yeah you did on the, whatchamacallit, Stooge's film. I had that shelf haircut in the 80s
where you cut it from the back. Did you really? Yeah. That sounds very Depeche Mode. It's T? Yeah. That sounds very Depeche Mode. It's total, it's TDM, total Depeche Mode. I had like kind of long and then it's short in the back. Ew, you had it like covering one of your eyes? Yeah, just kind of like coming up, you know.
Archie's kind of got that, right? You're all the sun there, listener. He's got a little bit of a what's that? Kind of looking through his hair. Now it's kind of long all around. What's that? That's a what's that, kind of looking through his hair. Now it's kind of long all around. What's that? That's a what's that haircut? What's that?
Yeah, I can't hear you because my hair is blocking my eyes, not my ears. Richard Ehrlich, the last thing he says to himself before he leaves, what's that? Yeah, yeah, our buddy, the most incredible real estate broker in the world. He is so good. If you're looking to buy a home in Los Angeles area.
Especially in the west side of Los Angeles area. Tricky Dicky Ricky Ehrlich. Richard Ehrlich is your guy. Yeah, he's amazing. And he's also an OG super fan of Smart Lips. Yes, so hello to Richard if you're listening. Richard's got a, Richard's got, I may have bored you with this before,
he's got a mirror face like we all do, but he's got a trigger sentence that launches that mirror face. You know, everyone's got a face that they use. What's a mirror face? Well, when you look in the mirror, when you wanna look your best, like one last look to go out,
you kinda tighten up the eyes, you maybe turn your head a little bit. Well, Fon's had a, right? Like that was exactly, right. The mirror face, okay. So what Richard does to prompt the mirror look he's looking for is he pretends that he is asking someone for directions, right?
He's pulled up in his car next to someone walking their dog maybe, and he asks them directions, and they give them the directions, and he looks forward over a steering wheel, and then he figures, well, maybe I didn't hear it correctly, and then he'll turn to his left, to the person, and he'll go, it's where? And so it's where, the combination of the turn
and the question will tighten up the eyes just enough and give him just enough disdain to look sexy. It's where? Yeah, that's a good red carpet photo. Sexy disdain, that's the new one, right? Yeah, he never looks hotter than when he says it's wear. Which is so crazy because he's such a nice guy. He's a nice guy and he's nice looking,
but he just is not good with directions. Sean, good morning. Good morning to you. What have you done so far today aside from putting on some smartless swag, I see there on your body? You know, he's always wearing smartless shit, Will. Like we're televising this and he's helping move merchandise. I wear it because I really like it.
I sleep in it. He sleeps in it. And Sean, what was the sleep schedule last night? Cause you have a weird, you wake up at the night and then you go back to bed early in the morning. I go to bed at about midnight. I get up at about 3 a.m., I stay up until about six or seven,
then I fall back asleep for a couple hours, and I'm good to go. And then I need like a 10 minute nap. And then I'm good to go. Total chaos, and then I'm good to go. It is total chaos. I'll send emails at three or four in the morning. I know, oh I know. Oh, I know.
Oh, I know. Don't start doing Will. By the way, I love the way your impression of me just has the dumbest look on your face. Oh, I know. You know what we've done here, Sean, though? We've boosted up young Willie. Willie started this, started the pod a little bit down,
a little bit out of sorts, and then there's just a little bit of love. And now the wings are flapping. All right, tighten up, guests, here we come. Today, we have a guest who's a giant in many categories. She's a titan in music, acting, producing, philanthropy, business, and social media. If you wanted to describe a person who's uniquely suited
to soar in today's media and cultural systems, you would simply say her name. I think I know who this is. She's a Grammy, Emmy, SAG, Golden Globe, and Critics Choice Nominated musician, actress, and producer. Her music has amassed 34 billion streams globally. She's got a movie coming out, a TV show that's already on,
and a company that exceeds 300 million in sales annually. And when she's not running those things, she's keeping up with her 428 million followers on Instagram. What else needs to be said, guys? Please welcome the lazy, unaccomplished, unmotivated, and perpetually failing Miss Selena Gomez. Woohoo! Woo hoo! Oh boy. I'm motivated.
I'm motivated, perpetually failing. It was so hard not to laugh, it was so hard. Oh my gosh, Selena, hello. Hi. Hi guys, I'm so happy to be here. I'm so happy you're here. This is a very nice thing you're doing for us and our listeners.
Oh no, this is more my thing, I'm so happy. It here. This is a very nice thing you're doing for us and our listeners. Oh no, this is more my thing. I'm so happy. It's pretty cool of you. If we didn't know, it looks like you were lying in bed in sheets. We have an overhand shot. Yes, well that is my beautiful background that I made for you guys,
because I figured that would be better than random. You're keeping it real. Listeners, she's got just a sheet draped over just a bunch of dead bodies behind you Good work. Thanks. Yeah, I'm a segue into murders So, oh, yeah. Well, we're gonna get to that. We're gonna get to that. So Selena Where do we find you this morning? Are you in Los Angeles? I am I am home right now And I just had my coffee and yep. What time do you usually get up every morning?
I'm a 6.30 guy. I'm about seven, 7.30. Are there animals to feed? Yes, I have two dogs. You do? What kind? They're little multi-poos. They're pretty annoying but cute.
Two the same. Is that because your body gets you up at seven or are you just like me? No, my body does. I think, I don't know, for some reason, maybe the show or something, it's just embedded in me that I'm automatically up and then I feel like a piece of shit if I wake up at like ten.
Sure. Even though those are nice. What is that about the body that will just wake you up at the same time every single day? Circadian rhythm. Wurveling at the body. Look at this guy. Yeah. And then if you just point it,
and then if you point your eyes at something, it tells your brain what you're seeing. Uh-huh. A miracle. It's just a miracle. It's so much discovery. You're like a one man Spielberg movie. Just a wonderment of discovery.
Guys, if you put one foot in front of another, you'll just end up moving forward. That's incredible. All right, so Celia, with these two dogs, they're Maltese, Malty Poo's. Yes. So that's a combo, right? Yes, they're very cute.
They're brother and sister? No, they are, I got them at two different times, but they definitely don't act like brother and sister. No. Rescue's Pure Breads, we can cut that if you want. No, no, no. I actually am not afraid to say, during COVID I was very scared and lonely
and I found one on Craigslist because the mom was like, we had babies and we don't know what to do. Yes, they were like, we don't know what to do, our dog had puppies like, we don't know what to do our dog had puppies So I was like, I'll take one clear out for a joke. Go ahead. Well, no Though they like drove in from Vegas and like rolled the window halfway down and passed me the dog and wanted the cash I was like, all right my my I did have a bad experience. I did have a bad experience one
Here we go. I posted on Craigslist. Yeah said, who wants, for a hundred bucks you wanna come out and check out these puppies? And let me say, when I got to his house, it was not. Dogs. A dog. It was not dogs. Come check out these puppies for a hundred bucks.
Thank you, Will. Thank you, you rest again. All right, let's. Will. Thank you. You rest again. Um, alright, um, let's... Will's having a literal spintank in his own mouth. Um, we're a little sloppy this morning. We are super sloppy. Selena, isn't it better to get this over with than in the afternoon? No, I actually don't mind this. This is a great way to start my day.
You guys are making me laugh. Well, keep your knees bent. It's not over yet. We'll let you revisit that at the end to see if you still love it. All right, now Selena, you're incredibly accomplished. You started very young. I wanna know, so you started with acting, yes,
because mom was an actor and got you kind of interested in that, question mark? Yeah, she actually never pressured me or said that's what I should do. She just did a lot of theater growing up, so she never really did anything television-wise. And I was seven when I got my first job because I was only child, super dramatic, and I was like, I got my first job because I was only child, super dramatic,
and I was like, I'm so capable of this. And I did- Kind of all it takes. Yeah, it's true. But it worked, and I've just been working ever since, and I feel really lucky. Was this Barney? That was Barney, the purple guy.
Oh, that's crazy. You were in Barney? Started with Barney. Yes. That's amazing. That's pretty rad. The guy who played Barney, he was pretty hot. Was he? Yeah, he was hot. He had to be fit and cute because he was in this.
No way. Hot Barney. This is changing everything. That's a new doc. So he was a plushie. Yeah. I'm sorry, Sean. Just quick for Tracy really quick. Does Tracy need to know this? Does she want to know what a plushie is? I thought she's like a fetish where people dress up in like costumes and stuff, right? No, I heard no
Yes, what do you mean? Right? Thank you. You don't need to say right question mark to us Yeah, we're gonna air something or something or that is correct John Alright so we're with Barney and we're having fun on that and then how did that happen? I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna cool to be on TV. Yeah, I mean my mom wasn't very intense about what I could watch. So I would stay up and watch Friends with her and Will and Grace. And that was like what I grew up with. Barney and Will and Grace. For the longest time by the way on my bio on Instagram says, I love Will and Grace.
No way. That's so sweet. For like a solid year and then everyone was like, can you maybe change that?. No way. That's so sweet. Yeah, for like a solid year, and then everyone was like, can you maybe change that? I was like, That's very sweet. Did you ever see the episode where Will was in a dance off with Sean?
With Janet Jackson. With Janet Jackson? You did? I was a backup dancer. I played a backup dancer. Oh, that's right, and then Karen got mad because she fell for you, And yes, I remember. Yes. Oh my God. You really are a fan.
Wait, Will, I remember you snapping those moves. I think I was there that night, right? You were there that night. You really know how to finish a move. Remember how hard we played before? But we're so tired and Jimmy's like, okay, let's do it again. I looked at Sean and I'm like, we're going to do it again. But Selena, do you know just as a Will and Grace superfan, you know that there's a podcast that Sean does
called Just Jack and Will that he does with Eric McCormack. No, I do know. I actually do know. And I remember my friend sent me the link because she knew that I was obsessed and I had no idea. No way. Yeah. Sean, did you know that Selena Gomez
was such a huge Will and Grace fan? I did because I'm really good friends with Marty short Oh, and then we chatted on the phone me and Selena chatted on the phone like a year ago or something and you were like Oh my god, and I was like, oh my god No likewise No, I'm very I'm very excited I With you so me too and I grew up with you, so. Me too, and I grew up with you. Now. 53, 53 years.
All right, so we're galloping along with acting. We've got the Barney under our belts. We'll move into Waverly Place. Yes, my Disney show. Yes, and a few other jobs here and in there, and things are really moving. And cooking. And then there's a cooking show later, we're gonna get to that.
But when did music start to tap you on the shoulder and say, hey, come this way? Well, I think that Disney is safe to say they're a machine, and they kind of, in a a way not forcefully required that I know how to sing so I could sing like the theme song like they know how to package someone and like make it like a whole triple threat thing. This was happening during Waverly? Yeah.
So they asked me to do the theme song and I had fun with that and then they were like, would you like to do the theme song and I had fun with that and then they were like, would you like to do an album? I thought it would be fun and I thought more than anything it would be like a hobby that I really enjoyed. And then I wanted to be a serious actress. I was 15. And I wanted to be an actress. I never really intended on being a singer full time
but apparently that hobby turned into something else. Now, did you have any idea that you could sing before you tried it? Yeah, well I was on Barney and I did do, I love you. You love me. Wow, that's not very challenging. And you know, it warmed up my vocals.
Okay, all right. There you go. And then because of that, did you take singing lessons and develop your instrument, as they say? You know, I did. I don't think I'm the best singer, but I think I know how to tell stories, and I love being able to make songs that,
you know, I get more, like, I always get people coming up to me saying, I had no idea it was you that was singing that song, and that kind of makes it feel nice. It makes, to me saying, I had no idea it was you that was singing that song. And that kind of makes it feel nice. It makes it to me that I feel like it's just about the song then. I mean, Wizards of Waverly Place was a gigantic hit show. Yeah, I miss it.
I wanna say my sister wrote on that for a second. Really? She was a writer on that maybe. I might not be remembering. But it was a blast. Like I will say yes. That's why I love sitcoms. Would you say you have a good memory, Jason?
No, not really. Okay. Wayne, we're going to get right back to you. But Selena, I want to... It's Will, actually. So, what is it? It's Will. Thank you, Scott.
So... Oh my gosh, the bits. I love the bits. I love the bits. I love it. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. All right, so then you know that you can kind of sing a little bit and the music starts to take off.
Like, I guess what I'm asking is at what point was the acting and the music at the same level, and you thought, do I have to pick, or should I try to keep both these things going at the same speed? I started having a lot of fun with music, and then touring was really fun. But I was doing my TV show at the same time. Wizards, and I just, I found it wizards, and I just,
I found it really fun, so I just kept going, but the older I get, the more I'm kinda like, I would like to find something to just settle on. Yeah. Well, it's exhausting, right? I mean, that sounds like super, that's so hard. I just think about the energy, this is such an old game. Oh my God, I went to a mental institute
and canceled one of my tours, like, ooh. Really? Because of too much work. It was so exhausting. Yeah, it just got to me, because I love working and it distracts me from bad things and I like that, so I just like working. I was just saying that this morning.
By the way, it reminds me, my three-year-old Denny, he calls lizards, because he can't say El, he calls them wizards. So he's always like, there's a wizard in the backyard. I hope he's right. I really hope there's a wizard in the backyard. Because I don't want to talk to him. But wait, but Selena, you're saying that in a perfect world you would pick either one or the other going forward Well, I do feel like I have one more album in me, but I would I would probably choose acting you would yes
Damn, you're so great at music though Yeah, yeah, I mean here's the good news you don't have to pick don't have to pick you right But I am gonna want to chill cuz I'm tired. Mm-, I mean, reading through, I can tell you, we've had some very accomplished people on this show. Thank you listeners for making it a place where accomplished people want to come. I have never read so much information about a guest than I have about you.
I mean, the things you have done in your, I mean, you're just barely 30, aren't you? 31. It's just so admirable what you've done. Thank you. It's mind blowing. In philanthropy and in global sort of charities and being in, what, a UNICEF ambassador?
I was a UNICEF ambassador and now I have my own foundation. Yeah, it's just stunning. And we haven't even gotten to Rare Beauty, this beauty company, the makeup company, what do you call it? Rare Beauty. Yeah, but I mean what would you describe it as, a beauty company? Yeah, I would say cosmetics.
It's been really fun but we're actually starting to get into skin now. I know this is all girly stuff, but I'm excited. It's definitely. I'm wearing makeup right now. Yeah, exactly. I know, but we're going into skin now. It's about three years old,
and it's honestly been the biggest gift, because I launched it during COVID, and it just took off, and I couldn't be more thankful. Did you launch it during COVID and it just took off and I couldn't be more thankful. Did you launch it during COVID because you had time to finally, because you weren't on tour and you weren't shooting, you're like, now I have time to dedicate to this?
Or it kind of came up or was it something you always? It sucked. I was supposed to release it like a month right into COVID. So I had done all the promotion and everything. It's about to come out. And then we figured, all right, we'll just try online. And I think makeup became really big during COVID because people would do the videos
and they would create looks. And it kind of just took off. And I'm always confused and just grateful because I've never been the type of person that want, I don't want to be or need to be the number one anything. And I think that's what my mom has instilled in me because I don't feel like anything's a competition. So I feel like there's room for everyone.
So I'm really proud. Do you think like, when you started Barney at seven and then Wizards and then all that, do you think that your work ethic and your drive and your ambition was instilled in you or would have happened to any way? Oh, I don't know. I probably would have been a hot mess
if I wasn't doing this, I already am. But I don't know, I don't know. We are all hot. Obviously tell us how. Oh, I've been to like four treatment centers and woo. Just because of depression and anxiety, right? Yeah, yeah, and I'm bipolar as well. Carry on top.
I would say you've got an incredible dynamic head on your shoulders that takes a lot of management and analysis and it sounds like you're doing a pretty fricking good job. Yeah, no kidding. Thank you. I don't know, Disney was like boot camp. They were definitely.
You know who doesn't have problems? You know who doesn't have problems, Lena? Dummies. You know, I mean, that's where you get that blissful ignorance, that's where it comes from. You need to be really smart to be complicated. Yeah, and I'm pretty, I don't know. I can be a little.
Yeah, I think you're doing great. It's not getting in your way of your accomplishments, and you and I have talked a few times. You're incredibly nice, so your personal success is fantastic as well as opposed to your business success. So whatever you're doing, keep going. Yeah. Are you super excited?
So your mom, as you said, your mom is or was an actress and kind of that sort of paved the way for you to get into it and take it seriously. And you mentioned you're an only child. Imagine you're still pretty close with your folks. Yes. And was that like, when you started to make that transition into becoming a star at a really young age,
what was that dynamic like with your folks? How much did you rely on them to kind of be there? And how has that relationship changed as you've gotten older? I mean, do you notice it? Yeah, I think when I was younger, my mom, I mean, my mom was my mom, mean my mom was my mom I was under 18 So I was getting invited to these events and stuff and my mom
From a very early age was like you're gonna walk the carpet Maybe we'll stay for five minutes, but then adult times probably gonna happen and you know It's like the Vanity Fair parties and all that stuff. So she was um She was always very protective of me, but it never really felt like it was suffocating. And she would always say the same thing to me. She said, the moment you stop having fun, stop. It's okay. You know, like you don't need to just kill yourself
over something if you're not happy. Yeah, because of the hours. Right, and the hours of, people don't understand that the hours and hours and hours of work that it takes to do a TV show, a tour, whatever it is, or a movie, it's just like for a kid. It's hard enough to be a kid. I just think about my own kids and being young teenagers,
my older boys that I'm just thinking about. And then the younger ones with the speech problems. Right, I was looking for wizards. Wizards. It's like the idea of them, like Sean, we were over there watching the movie the other night with Archie. Can you imagine Archie, he's 15,
being on the road and working all the time. I think like, no, he wouldn't be able to. He wouldn't be happy, is what Selena's saying. It's tough, right? It's tough. No, it is. And the transition honestly happened around 25 where I didn't feel like I had to impress
my parents more so. But my mom was also really cool because right after Disney she put me in a movie called Spring Breakers. Like she found that movie and it's, you know, very racy. Yeah, very. But it was fun. Yeah, and it wasn't, I mean, I'm sure your mom was not strategic with grabbing that, nor were you, but I'm sure that there was some thought put into it where this would sort of broaden the public's idea about that which you can do and that which is fitting
of when they think about you, she can do this, she can do that. And or was it just a part of like, well, this is a little bit closer to who she's starting to become, not somebody who's... My mom was a huge Harmony Corrine fan and she heard there was a script out and so she was interested in it. And the character I play isn't as racy, so I was like 19 when I did it and she just came up to me
and she was, this will make no sense and you're probably gonna think I'm crazy, but just read this. And I read it and I don't know, I gravitated towards the character and then I met Harmony and I was like, oh, game over, he's just really cool. How did your mom have the sense to know good material from bad material or the right material?
She's really great at that stuff. She found the book 13 Reasons Why, which we turned into a TV show, so she randomly was at a bookstore and she was a young adult and found that and we developed it. She just has really nice taste, you know? And instincts, clearly.
Yeah, she's really great. So I like to ask her advice on things. That's great. That's awesome. I love that you guys are so close. Yes. You know, we can cut this part too, but I am fascinated and thankful for how outspoken you are about mental health.
Because I have somebody very, very close to me who I've had to deal with it, and not deal with it, but just like help with it, and I was happy to help with it. But do you ever? Well, say thank you to him. You've never publicly thanked him well. No, I was gonna say the same thing, all jokes aside, Jason, you dick, I was gonna say, oh no, JK.
I was gonna say, I like the way that you're so open and frank about that, about mental health. And I think that it's something that people, luckily talk about more and more, but I think it's really refreshing to hear you talk about it in a way that's very just sort of matter of fact. And I think it's really, I don't know, it shows real maturity and it shows, I think it's really, I don't know, it shows real maturity and it shows,
I think it's very brave and I think it helps so many people the way that you talk, honestly, in that way. I really do, it struck me. I think it's really remarkable. It is, it's great because my mom died of Alzheimer's a long time ago. I forget when.
Da da da da da da. And because I, because it was so painful, because it was so painful, I just, me and my sister and my family, because it was so painful, because it was so painful, I just, me and my sister and my family, we would, there's a point where you have to start making it funny. Because you've cried too much about it, so then you cut it with humor, and I have the funniest Alzheimer's stories ever
because I lived through it and it was so tragic that my mom, we can cut this too, but my mom would go to the bathroom, she'd go number two in the toilet and I'd walk in there, I'd go, mom, you have to flush the toilet. She goes, I don't know who did that. I don't know who that is. They came in here when I wasn't here,
they went to the bathroom. We cannot prove that that's mine. We cannot prove that that's mine. And we would laugh because it was past the point. So my question is, have you, me dealing with somebody with no sense. Have I taken a shit and forgotten? No, no, no, no.
Have you ever? No, have you ever? Like, have you ever just kind of infused humor into the whole situation? Definitely. I also have a few friends that are in comedy and writers and it's just fun. Now me and my family are in a place where we can do that. I don't mind saying the things that I'm walking through and they can be fun and they can be
messy but I've always just. You take the power back. Yeah, just knowing more, I feel better. And it gives so many people, myself included, a little bit more comfort in the reality that I'm not, you know, I'm kind of broken upstairs. We all are. There are as many mental variables in all of us
as there are physical ones. You can see the physical ones. Someone's taller, someone's shorter, someone's thicker, someone's thinner, someone's got bigger feet, smaller feet. Like, there are equal number of variables in the brain and the fact that we've got medicine, therapeutics, an environment that is tolerant of all of those variables nowadays
as opposed to back when our parents were our age. And Jason, on top of that, community. The idea that you're talking about it, it sheds a light and says you're not alone, there's somebody else, and somebody else can relate to that and identify with it. Certainly I know from my own life, and somebody else says I have this,
and they go, oh, and they talk I have this, and they go, oh. And they talk about their experience, and I go, oh, you have this too. And then we can talk about it in a way that, and that kind of really breaks it wide open. It definitely, it connects you as well. I mean, that's why I released my documentary. It's all based on mental health.
Thank you so much. I haven't seen it, I'm so, forgive me, I'm gonna watch it. Oh, no, it's, don't worry. No, pause, we're gonna watch it. It's really kind of sad. No, no, I'm putting it on here. But it ends well.
I just, I think that's why I did the documentary. I was terrified before it came out and I had already signed the contract and I was like, damn, I can't go back. But that was a really big moment for me. And then I had people coming up to me not saying like, oh my God, can I have a picture a picture they would say I've dealt with depression or I've done this and then I end up having a connection with people yeah I love that
sometimes with all my health stuff like I've had a kidney transplant I have high blood pressure I gosh I have mental mental health and I don't even know. I'm sure I have other problems that I'm not aware of. I love talking about all that. But you can think about a situation and say, why me, why me? And instead, it's given me the gift to say, oh, I know why it's me.
I'm there for those people that are going through what I went through and I can say, I hear you and I see you, not just be in and say my life's perfect, but I'm sorry, you know, it's like, well, I can be honest with you. I'm a big believer that the person upstairs, or whomever's upstairs for anybody, doesn't give you anything more than what you can handle.
Yes. And so the fact that you've been given all of these gifts, challenges, and that you're able to go through them so successfully in a public space such that you can give encouragement and support to others is like, I mean, talk about using your years right. We've talked about it on the show before,
about when you get to the end, we're all gonna look back and hope that we used our time correctly. I mean, the first 30 years of your life have been incredibly accomplished spiritually, mentally. Certainly. Yeah, I guess the question really is, Slayne, now what?
Yeah. Yeah. You know, you're fixing your brain, you're fixing the world. Better follow it up. Yeah. I don't know, I think I just, I gravitate towards things I connect to,
and I'm all about authenticity. I can't really force myself to be anything other than who I am, and it's just, you know, luckily worked. It's so good. I'll bet your ability to recognize and attract those who are equally authentic is really keen too. You know, like I was just thinking
when you were talking about the documentary, thinking about Alec Ashishian and his sister, Aline, we both work with. I mean, people like that, like you probably have a great team around you, great friends around you, like all of us as we get older, you have less and less friends, but that's usually by choice. Talk to us about your ability to kind of pick up on people's uniqueness and authenticity or lack thereof. Is that something you always had or has it just gotten sharper? Maybe it has gotten sharper, but ever since I was younger, I had, I like to think I had good discernment with people and I could just sense when I felt that it was being forced
or that there was something they were wanting or whatever. I just could feel that in a lot of people. And I mean, obviously I put some of those people in my life when I was younger and then I later realized, but most of my friends, like I said, they can go from being a writer to one of my friends is a realtor, so I kinda... Is that Richard Ehrlich?
I kinda just... It's not Richard Ehrlich, is it? No. Yeah, well, it's having people skills, right? And I wonder if you're like me, that's part of what has always attracted me to being an actor, is because I'm just fascinated with people and I really enjoy kind of reading people
and seeing is this person a match for me or not. And I just wonder what that is. Also it's just staying curious, right? The moment you stop being curious, then like Jason just said, you become one of those dummies. Yeah, I know. I love life and I love people and I find it really fun. Do you find that, which do you find
is more cathartic for you, more sort of a lane to explore and enjoy parts of you? Is it with playing different characters or being a songwriter? I think it's a little bit of both. I wrote this ballad called Lose You to Love Me and that was probably the most personal song I'd ever released about something that was on everyone's mind for some reason.
And then in acting, I feel like I have these moments in my life that have happened and I'm able to use that and it actually feels great. And it feels, you know, like after a good cry or something, it's like a good feeling. And... Is there something that you... I mean, this is going to be one of the dumbest questions you've ever gotten. Is there something with every single thing that you've done where you're just like, you know what I've never done? I need to do that before.
Oh yeah. I don't think I even began like in a lot of areas. Like I'm not necessarily cosmetics and stuff, but like I've said many times with you guys, I think acting, like I don't think I've been able to even touch the surface of what I know that I'm capable of doing. And I'm very selective or else I'd be in all of the movies that I get offered. And I just fight for my roles and I'm always auditioning.
So I like to earn it. Yeah, good, that's great. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Something I've sort of really gotten more and more passionate about is not playing characters as much as just playing somebody that doesn't Force me to to do a lot of acting and play a character I kind of like to be the audience and a lot of that comes from my desire to try to be as not full of
Shit as possible in my life and and not be fake and phony and pretending to be other people. So I really like Trying to be as authentic as I can. Do you have a similar sort of battle when you think about acting? Because you're so good about being really you and being in your skin and being honest. Does that run counter to the whole thing that we try to do as actors? Kind of. But I just finished this movie, this Jacquardillard film, and it's all in Spanish and it's a musical, and it was one of the most challenging things that I had done.
Wow, wow, that's cool. But it's really, what's it called? Emilia Perez, I think that will come out next year. But it's so good if you just said none of your business. I know. None of your business. I'm excited for that because there's, for example, there's the scene where I'm being left, I'm not for that because there's, for example, there's the scene where I'm being
left and not giving anything away. And I remember I channeled the moment when I had to go to rehab for the first time and leaving and I remember I told my co-star that's what I was feeling in the moment. And I just felt like it was getting that out when I remembered that first moment and being terrified. That's what I was feeling in the moment. And I just felt like it was getting that out when I remembered that first moment and being terrified. So it felt really cathartic. Speaking of that, have you ever wanted to go to the Broadway or do live theater? I'm not sure I'm there yet, because I think I'd still be a little nervous.
Oh, really? After touring and stuff, you've already been a stage performer. No, but it's different, because I love when I'm doing my concert, because it's like, oh, these are my peeps. And you feel comfortable. You feel safer, yeah, yeah, for sure. Will you talk more about that, about battling?
Because I get very nervous when I have to speak publicly. Like I can't even give a toast. Really? Yeah, he goes white. Yeah, but I have an enormous amount of confidence when it comes to other things that are going to be made for the public. Like being in front of a camera.
Right, for millions of people as opposed to 10 people at a dinner table. are going to be made for the public. Millions of. Like being in front of a camera. Right, for millions of people as opposed to 10 people at a dinner table. So I don't understand that about myself, the difference between having a lot of confidence or zero confidence that are sort of similar things. How do you. Because Jay, because you're so well spoken in life,
just I mean clearly in life, that's why it blows my mind that anytime we're at like a dinner party, or like two, three years ago, we are at your birthday dinner party at Richard's house. And I said, let's go around the room and say, how grateful, how much we love Jason, and I'll start. And I got up and I gave this little speech, and it got to Jason, and you were like, I'm out. I don't want any part of this.
It's like, goodbye. But yeah, so how do you manage that? Like what is that switch that flicks for you when you can stand up in front of 100,000 people and give a concert or do a movie or television show that's gonna be for millions of people versus like maybe going out on a date for the first time or doing an interview for a magazine,
or whatever might give you anxiety, do you know what that is, that different thing? Because I'm still trying to figure it out with myself. I think when I was younger, I had a very, very public life, and it wasn't fair in a lot of ways that I got to the point so much so that I was like if I don't talk about what's going on everyone's gonna continue to narrate my life and people are just gonna buy it and I need people
to hear from me and I genuinely stopped caring like I don't I don't care like I would be happy to stand up and speak very highly of someone. I'd be happy to do it. Even if I mess up, I'm like, all right, well, that sucked. But I tried. It's fine. So I don't know if I've done it for too long that I just have lost a little bit of that fear. But I still get the butterfly feeling. Yeah, so maybe I just got used to it And I'm kind of like well people are gonna like it or not. Yeah, I have a friend of mine Maria Shriver she you know I've known her for years and years and decades and she I Whenever I would have dinner at her house. She she's the one who forced me to get up and talk like that and it's so I was
littered you know, sorry, I was riddled with fear about it. And, but she forced me to do it. She's like, we're gonna go around and stand up and speak how you feel. And I was like, pass. I'm going to the next person. Were you so nervous because you had just littered? Is that what it was?
Yeah. Like, I'm having a tough time following what happened. But, but Jay, Jason. But now that you're saying it, I think for me, it's like I'm afraid of being accused or judged as either being full of shit or being stuck up. I had a real complex about being conceited and stuck up when I was in middle school. Like sixth and seventh grade was really hard for me in school because people, oh, here comes that guy on TV.
He's stuck up. So I wasn't really, I was shy about being confident because people would think I was stuck up. So then I tried to seem not confident and then maybe that part of me kind of took hold. But what's crazy about that though is, think about it, that's inauthentic. Yeah, exactly.
If you think about it, you fell victim to the very thing that you were trying to prevent. I mean that honestly. And when you're thinking about it that much, you put a space between you and people you're trying to connect with, Jay. I really mean it. And if you can break that down and react in real time,
then it will never be inauthentic. But the second you start thinking about, you're trying to curate what other people think of you, that's inauthentic. Yeah, and it makes me so nervous because I'm having to manage two things at the very same time. Right, right. Because you're taking care of their feelings before yours.
Yeah, you're never gonna be able to, I remember somebody saying, what, you can't tell everybody how to treat you or how to look at you. There's nothing you can do about the way people think about you. All you can do is take it. None of your business.
Well, yeah, there's that and also, you'll never get to it. Selena, one second. Yeah, that's fine. No, it's okay, I'm enjoying this. I like this conversation. But really, just really quick, it's the same thing that I've carried around
for so long being gay, is like, I've constantly my entire life, I just came out, my entire life, I spent taking care of other people's feelings and putting mine second, and then you have to reach a point where Selena's saying, we're like, I can't, I'm exhausted by taking care of other people's feelings and putting mine second. And then you have to reach a point where Selena is saying, we're like, I can't, I'm exhausted. But why did you do that for being gay?
With regards to you being gay, is that what you mean? Yeah, yeah. Like if I enter a room, even today, I still have a little bit left over, but for the most part I don't care. It's like I have to check, like I'm so used to, it's in my blood now, to check how people think about me entering a room. Are they thinking about my being gay or not?
I used to do this when I was younger. I remember I was doing an interview and I sat down and there was probably 14 people behind the camera and I think I was maybe 21. I the camera, and I think I was maybe 21, and I started to sweat, and I ran away, and I started crying. Because this is what I was thinking. I was like, these people probably think I sound stupid.
They're going to go home and tell their partners or friends about how much of an idiot I am, and I feel like a horrible interviewer. It used to kill me. Yes, it would kill me. Really? A panic attack, yeah. I've had that, and I couldn't, I was stuck there.
And it just becomes exponentially more horrific and terrifying because now you're convinced, now they can see that I'm having a panic attack. Now it gets even worse. It's like, oh yeah, yeah. And so. You have that too, huh? I mean, I still fall back into it,
but I've caught here and there, but for the most part I'm like. I really mean this, I'm sure there'll be a lot of listeners like shut the fuck up, really this is new to me, I don't understand it in that way. Everybody's wired differently. It's a form of parenting. Like when I got this, you know, when I got this.
And I was so, obviously. He's holding up just some sort of, just plain white faceless body. And I thought, okay, thank you everybody. But I feel like the older I get, the closer I get to our favorite term, sexy indifference. Or rather, better said,, sexy indifference, or rather, better said, a healthy indifference,
where you do care what people think, but you're not obsessed by it and you're not pulled around by it. I will challenge you on that because we're doing it right now today. That is also put on. It's not real, because if you have to think about the sexy indifference,
then it's not organic. Right. You know what I mean? I'm trying to get to that place of honest and healthy indifference where it's just right sized. Where you do care about people, you don't wanna be rude, you wanna be sensitive to people. You just wanna seem desperate. The freedom is when you don't even have to recognize
that you do have indifference, that you're just living. That's the freedom. Otherwise, you're shackled by the idea of it. It still lives there as an idea. I think. But it's also what we do for a living, right? It's part of our job to be aware of what people think and kind of manipulate that.
And like, we're professional liars, you know? And so it was a little bit of a head screw for me, obviously still is, when I was a kid. When you're trying to figure out who you are and who you're becoming, you're training yourself how to fake to be somebody else. It's kind of a little bit of a blender. It's very weird. Do you still think about that, Selena?
Absolutely. I remember I was talking about this with someone and there was a study that said, the moment you get famous at a certain age, you end up stuck in that area for a while because it's- Emotionally. Yes, because it stunts, you're dealing with things that no child
should be dealing with and criticizing my body or something weird, like it just, it felt, ugh, it just doesn't feel good. You can't grow privately like most people do. Yeah, so I mean I don't regret my life, but there's a huge part of me that's like, yeah, I wonder what that would have been like to just be me for a second. So, but this, I'm assuming that you've got millions,
literally millions of people that admire you more than any of us could probably imagine because of how brave you are with how honest you are. And that is not going to go away, thank God. I mean, you're a role model whether you like it or not. Until I run away from everything. No, no, you're not gonna go, wherever you go you're gonna be there.
No, don't take away her out until you run away, if you want. I've run away. But I now get it though, Jay, I wanna say, you just mentioned that, I wanna say that I now get it when I sort of earlier, flippantly when we first started talking about how many millions of followers you have, I now understand, I get it now,
your relationship with that number, with those numbers of people is tricky. And I sort of have a little bit more of an understanding, I really mean that, maybe I'm a slow learner. But I. No, no, it's weird, it's such a bizarre thing. have a little bit more of an understanding. and it's like, I don't need this information. I just want to post a photo and let it be for my fans and move on.
And they are definitely attracted to all the things that are very special about you and not to take away from any of that, but I think it is also very indicative of how common it is for people around the world to be not perfect. And I think they really are comforted by how you are so honest about how not perfect you are. And I think that's just a real gift
that you give to people. And myself included, I thank you for that. I cannot believe we're already past an hour. This is literally the fastest interview. Yeah, I'm stunned. We're not an hour right now, but it is pretty crazy. Yeah. I feel like we're just going to the surface.
I'm like, guys, let's go have brunch. I wanna let you go, but I know we have probably a couple more questions. Sean, go. Yes, no, I just wanna know, Only Murders, I love the show, I love you in it, I love Stephen Mardi. How did it come about? What was it like when you started? Did you just love Murders? How you got into Murders, I love the show, I love you in it, I love Stephen Mardi. How did it come about, what was it like when you started? Did you just love Murders, was that how you got into it?
To be honest, yes, and I like very dark documentaries sometimes, so I tend to lean into those, especially scary stuff, mentally. And John Hoffman is one of my very, very close friends. But no, it actually happened because, well, Steve's original idea was that it was going to be like mentally. Yeah. And John Hoffman is one of my very, very close friends of mine. I love him. So, but no, it actually happened because, well, Steve's original idea was that it was going to be three men. And then John Hoffman suggested that they hired...
He created the show. Yes, who created the show. He said, I think it would be really cool if we added like a younger character, maybe a female. We added like a younger character, maybe a female, and Steve liked the idea. And I guess this was really a gift because they had me in mind. And I remember thinking, I'm like, okay, well, what does this mean?
And then I had FaceTime with all of them, with Steve, Marty, and John, and producers. And I was like, oh, I just have to do this because simply the people are amazing. And then the success of it after. It's a good hang. Yeah, and then the success after was just
such a surprise and we just were happy to do it. Only murders in the building, never manslaughter. Never manslaughter. Never manslaughter, just murders. Okay, I'm fine, I'm allowed to ask. Yes you are. And that is in its fourth year or fifth year? Coming up on the fifth.
We just got renewed for season four. Season four. And we may have to cut this, but John, I asked John, I was like, how many more seasons? And he goes, well I asked Steve and Steve said forever. I know, he does. My favorite thing about Steve, and he knows that why ask Steve? And Steve said forever. I know he does. My favorite thing about Steve, and he knows that I've said this before,
but my favorite thing is Steve will be like, I've gotta get home. I gotta get home, I gotta go. I'm too old for this. And then I'll be like, well, I go, Steve, how many seasons do we do? He's like, oh, I don't wanna stop. We're gonna keep going.
And I'm like, what? He's just like. You've got to get home. Exactly, but you need to be home. So sometimes I'll be like, I'll carry the load because I get. It is the greatest trio, but as has been said before, one of the oddest trios ever. And it's just awesome.
It's awesome. It's infectious. Thank you. Awesome. Yeah. Thank you. Well, Selena, this has been great. Thank you, honey, for being here. Yeah, of course.
I just wanted to tell you, Jason, really quick. Yes, ma'am? I am gonna send your wife, Amanda, and your girls some of my new collection from Rare Beauty. Oh, you sweet thing. And like a whole little box, because I would love to see what they thought. They're enormous fans of yours, as Amanda my wife so I can I want to send you that
because this is gonna be this is gonna be one of the biggest collections that I've released and I'm beyond stoked for it I know it's it's little things like that that make me happy because yeah but it's not a little thing. It's really impressive what you've done with this. This company is potentially, if it's not already, bigger than anything you've done in music or in film or television. Absolutely. Or in social media.
I mean, it's an enormous company. And you really should be proud of that. But I think it's good products, and we also just try not to be everything else. You know, like I'm not huge on promoting like crazy, you know, makeup, I love makeup, but I want my line to represent yourself and to have fun with it.
It seems very consistent with you and what you represent. Yeah, well, might I say your skin is flawless. Oh my goodness, well, thank you. She takes off her glasses, she goes cross-eyed. She did a Richard Ehrlich earlier. What is it? Say, it's where? Say, he's a little bit confused,
and then that kid look at that beautiful. No, she's gonna let her say it's where. Say it, ready and action. No, it's where? I swear. Oh my God, that's good. That's really's where. Say it, ready and action. No, I swear. I swear. Oh my God, that's good. That's really good. You look just like Richard Ehrlich.
Great. Celina, you're the greatest. Thank you so much for doing this. This was a big, big get for us. It's so awesome to finally meet you too. I am so happy and hopefully I'll get to meet you all in person. I'm sure I'll run into you, Jason. I'm just, I'm a big fan of all of you
and I've really been wanting to do this for a while. I'm sure you know, Jason. So this has been really great. Thank you. Yeah, thank you for doing it. All right, have a great, great rest of the day and thanks for talking with us. All right, bye guys.
Bye, Selena, thank you. You see, now, guys, there's a nice person. You guys have asked me multiple times. You say to me, you say, Jason, how do I get, how can I become nice? How can I become nicer, you know, and be pleasant? Have success, isn't that your theory? Have success and then you're allowed to be nice.
Well, but then after that, try to be, not before, not before, because then they're gonna be accused of, somebody as kind and as gentle as loving as she is. What is that? Will's holding up a fake award. This is my dressing room, I don't know. It looks like an award. It looks like an Oscar. Yeah, she's really terrific.
Did you learn anything, you guys? I did, I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah, I's really terrific. What did you both, did you learn anything, you guys? I did, I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah, I think you are. Well, A, lazy, because she's just so, it seems like everything she does, she's successful at. Even mental health. Right. She's successful at that.
I know, right? Because she's not running from it, she's going right through it. She's just, it's pretty remarkable. And she's such a, talked about, we were talking, authenticity was a central theme today, and she's so authentic. Yeah, she's like a superhero.
She really doesn't, like she said, she just does what she loves to do. Everybody's welcome to come or don't come. Like, you know what's funny, I was gonna say, she said that she didn't care, but it's almost like she, it's not that she doesn't care, it feels like she just, what she cares about is just being herself and being honest about it.
Right, she turned that care internal. She's taking care of number one, which for me always lets me be a better person to the people around me. Sometimes I over-index in the selfishness, but I'm trying to get the right balance. Yeah. Yeah. No, sorry.
No. Did you? Still rolling. Let's get one more of those, Will. A little more convincing. Oh, no, Jason. I was, by the way, I held up on so many because it was such, so many things I wanted to throw in
and I didn't because it was just out of respect. Oh, so you've got some unused jokes you'd like to workshop real quick? I mean, no, no, no, no. There was one at the end certainly that I wanted to say. Yeah, let's hear it. Which is, don't worry, I'll carry the load, Steve. And I was like, Sean, how many times?
Okay, so. So you. Do you want to know. It's Steve, right? It's Steve, right? It's Steve. Do you want to know though, speaking about Archie, your son, you know, one time.
Uh-oh, here we go, this is a your son, you know, one time outside. No, no, this is outside once I had a wizard crawl up my pants. Did you really? Yeah. Truly? Truly, a lizard? A wizard.
And how hard did it get up before it pulled a quick 180 and said, no, thank you. No, that's such a funny thing, wizard. You could use it for so many things. Oh, you know what? Okay. So part of my, what is it called? The Gay Tray that Jason calls it.
Oh yeah, no, no, no, what? It wasn't this one. Yeah, no, the Gay Tray. It's an Invisalign thing. I didn't know you had it in today. Yeah, so I have it in every day, and then, but I can whiten my teeth. But my dentist, three days ago said,
you can hear some teeth whitening stuff you can put in the Invisalign trays. And, but you don't have to put them in the back where the... By Cuspids! Are. By. Smart. Smart. Smart. Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids!
Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids!
Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.